- You have a 16-month-old, right?
- Yeah, I do, yeah.
- That, I mean, okay.
And you just started on a new show,
which we're gonna talk about.
But here's the thing.
I felt like I went to work
too early with my first one,
and it was exhausting.
- It was exhausting, yeah.
- You started five months after, right?
- I started five months after,
but just acting is exhausting.
It's not like,
I don't know, it just takes
all of your mental capacity, kind of.
Like, I cried to my
mother-in-law week two,
'cause she came to help me,
and I was just, "I don't
know how I'm gonna do this."
- You just cried in week two?
- I just cried.
I was like, "I can't do this."
- I cried, like, every week.
(audience laughs)
It was week two for you.
- But before that,
I just was home.
I just stayed home.
But now recently,
like when he turned 10
months I got help finally,
because I have a weird job, you know.
I'm, like, home all the time,
but I also have to read and
do other things during the day
so I can't--
- Or you're gone all the time.
- Or I'm gone, yeah.
But now I got my own wife, I realize.
Like, having a nanny's like having a wife.
I'm like, "This is the best thing
"on the planet Earth."
I was like, "Bye.
"Have fun."
- She's safe and happy, bye.
- She's cooking an amazing
pesto dish for him.
This kid eats better than I
have ever eaten in my life.
- Oh my God, she's a chef too?
- Yeah, she does it all.
- Your kid lucked out, all right.
- He really did, He's spoiled
- I love that.